[Music]
[Applause]
Randall Chamblee Golf Channel leads
Studio analyst he's out of the studio
and he's at LACC one of my favorite golf
courses the north of course
um he joins us now on the program
Randall
what would you shoot if you played LACC
from the tips yeah I'll probably have a
hard time breaking 80. yeah I think
there are a lot of golfers that are
going to have a hard time trying to
break 80. I think that that's a tough
golf course but this is what the U.S
open wants is that correct that Parr is
going to be your friend
yeah he's a spectacular design Dan if
you've played it uh you know it's all
the buzz you know this is a town that
likes a good nip and Tuck uh and this
golf course
[Music]
in the golf architecture world uh a far
and wide lauded nip and Tuck uh and it's
architectural eye candy but I think it's
going to play spectacularly for the
Players Big Wide Fairways for the most
part but if you miss the fairways you're
going to play a tough price but it's the
green complexes that are
just out of this world if this golf
course we're on the ocean uh it'd
probably be ranked if not the best golf
course in the world right there behind
Pine Valley
yeah I agree I've played it a few times
and I'm just playing from the member
tees and it's challenging but I I told
the audience you'll be surprised that
the Rolling Hills like they're you're
not getting flat lies there that it's
it's got far more undulation than you
would expect at a golf course out there
that's true I mean people whose job it
is to to to dwell on architecture and so
forth say that this is probably the best
Parkland site imaginable for an
architect and you know obviously this
was a hundred or so years ago it's Gil
hans's line gilhand said that this golf
course uh I believe it's you know it is
paraphrasing a little bit but I think he
said this was the finest architecture
that he's ever seen and he's he's seen
more than his share
um and then you start to figure out
who's a favorite at an event like this
um I know that Scotty Scheffler
DraftKings has him is the favor then
John Rahm and then Rory and Brooks are
thrown in there and Patrick can't lay
what do you think of uh that lineup
there I think DraftKings nailed it uh
you know okay you always look at the
best players but when you get to a venue
like this where the fairways are so wide
uh and there's there's ample room to
just air it out for the best drivers and
the longest hitters in the game but then
there's this there's this really uh high
demand for precision coming into these
greens I mean they're they're small
targets they're angled there's a big big
price to pay if you miss them and Scotty
sheffler right now is he's almost as far
just in terms of ball striking the
distance between him and everybody else
is is almost tiger 2000 and everybody
else in terms of ball striking so
Scheffler leads you know Strokes getting
off the tee lead Strokes gain approach
uh you know it's more greens than
anybody you know at the memorial it was
the second best performance ever Strokes
Game T to green and he didn't win
because he's just well he's he's putting
like you and me probably uh if he just
puts decent just decent uh he should win
this event he could win it going away
we're talking to Randall Chamblee and
you can have uh the coverage the US Open
it'll be from Los Angeles LACC it'll be
on NBC uh also the wrap-up show that is
a wonderful show that Randall's there
with Rich Lerner and Company that's uh
after every round you can see it nightly
the drama from last week The Fallout and
you've had time to soak this in
has how is that time period helped or
hurt your thoughts on this merger with
Liv and PGA Tour
well I'm sure like everybody that heard
this they thought they were being punked
uh I did for sure uh but now that I've
had some time to talk to the people that
were really close to this deal
you know I said the other night that
probably the second worst thing that
could happen to golf is if this deal
went through and probably the worst
thing that could happen to golf is if it
didn't go through uh the plight of the
PGA Tour was such that you know they
were hemorrhaging money and legal fees
and also and trying to sustain these
these purses to compete with Liv to keep
players from being poached and going
over to live they weren't supported by
the ratings the ratings are fine in golf
uh golf's in a great spot but they don't
justify 25 million dollar purses and the
reward expectations of the tour players
have been Reese's reset I should say to
unsustainable levels
um so when you when you look at the
economics and you look at the fact that
Liv was not going to go anywhere the
Saudis weren't going to go anywhere
it seems you know more understandable
the deal was made but there's still this
impression that the tour sold
the professional game to the Saudis and
that is the pervading impression in all
of golf right now do you believe that
well when you dig into the details not
the not the actual PGA Tours we know
what this investment arm that they've
created this this uh this new entity
that's yet to have any specific goals uh
yeah you know and look the Saudis came
into the European tour as just a
tournament the next thing you know they
wanted to run everything and so now
they're in the room uh as the majority
investor
um I think it's pretty easy to look down
the line and think that they could
they could exercise undue influence in
the game of golf and when you consider
that there were other economic Solutions
no doubt I know of the economic
Solutions I've talked to people that
have offered the PGA Tour some money and
everybody gets enamored with this this
pith this pif fund for having 650
billion dollars and they're quick to say
that they have all the money in the
world but you know I've talked to a lot
of financial people in the last week and
they laugh at that they're like there is
a 140 trillion dollars of good clean
somewhat honest money all around the
globe and a lot of it is very interested
in aligning themselves with the PGA Tour
so there are other good clean economic
solutions that the PGA Tour could have
considered and if the deal doesn't go
through I'd say it's back on the table
uh and I think that would be far more
amenable to uh to the gulf public uh and
to the tour players I've tried to
approach this as just a golf fan that I
don't think they had altruistic motives
starting to live tour and Greg Norman he
wanted he had a vendetta against the PGA
Tour so I was disappointed you can take
the money I don't care go take the money
but I only cared about watching golf I
wanted to see the best players and I'm
wondering what the game is going to be
like in three years from now
well if the deal goes through it's
likely that live will be dissolved and
the players that had played on live will
have to sort of
work their way back into the PGA Tour
they'll have to pay a fine a substantial
fine no doubt but it'd be great to have
Brooks koepka and Dustin Johnson great
to have Phil Mickelson back it would be
look I mean these are interesting
players they were poached for a reason
they had tremendous appeal
but if the deal doesn't go through Dan
then your guess is almost as good as
mine because if the deal doesn't go
through innumerable things could happen
a lot of them bad players that felt
betrayed could jump ship go to live give
them more leverage it could go that way
it could go the way that I I sort of
hinted that a minute ago all of this
economic investment these economic
solutions that by and large is is let's
say just a lot cleaner than the Saudi
money could come into the game and Stave
off those potential defections but if it
doesn't go through your guess is as good
as mine
what's have you crossed paths with
Brooks koepka he had the line soon as it
came out welfare check on Chamblee uh
you know Phil Mickelson has had some
problems with you do you do you cross
paths with these guys at the U.S open
I walked the course a couple days ago in
the right behind Phil all day long uh
you know if I I look I'd asked him to
come up on the set he wanted to come up
on the set and debate and talk about Liv
I said look the seat's always welcome
for you love to have you up uh you know
at least from my view maybe there was
something I didn't know about Liv he
could come up because he's so invested
in it he could sell it maybe make more
money for everybody on those teams I
would be interested to hear the teams he
said look I don't want to help you guys
make any money I'm not coming up
he offered he offered a poor a Pierce
Morgan interview which coincides with
the U.S women's open which I'm working
so I had friends of mine reach out to
him I said look I'll sit down with you
on a podcast anytime anywhere and talk
about live all you want uh but you know
look they're going to take their shots
at me the day they took their shots at
me was what was that that was the
Tuesday the day it came out which was
ironic really because you know the next
day and talking to the people that
had a lot to do with this deal like if
this deal goes through Liv's going to
die those guys could could very easily
just have lost their jobs lost at least
one third of their contract money and
have to then come back and their boss
would be whoever the commissioner of the
PGA Tour is when there was news
yesterday that that Jay's uh taking some
time away to deal with some health
issues and we certainly wish him the
best but let's say Jay recuperates and
is still at the helm they have to come
through Jay Monahan who you know I'm not
sure he's going to be too lenient in
dishing out Their fines to come back
because you could make the argument I
certainly make it that they've Char they
they've harmed the PGA tour in in
irreparable ways
yeah I agree
um I'm just like how much can you find
Brooks kepka if he wants to come back to
the PGA Tour well it's been floated
around I think everybody pretty much
knows uh what he left for so take the
taxes away and there's your fine you
know
you can't irreparably damage the PGA
Tour benefit financially from it be
involved in legal issues along the way
which cost the PGA Tour loads of money
which otherwise would have been
reinvested in the tour or Pension funds
or purses uh and expect to come back and
still have the upper hand financially
with the people you're competing against
but could you see Rory getting equity in
the PGA Tour and John Rahm and Scotty
Scheffler
you know that's the thing look if if
this deal doesn't go through and I was
reading today just before I came on your
show CNBC was reporting that PGA Tour
players are considering outside Bankers
to take a look at this deal any outside
Bankers or investment that may come into
the PGA Tour I would say would be a heck
of a lot more rational than the
investment from the Saudi side and the
reward expectations as I just said a
little while ago have been reset amongst
PGA Tour players to unsustainable levels
and to re-anchor those reward
expectations uh to reality is going to
be difficult to do but any investor that
comes in is not going to say look we
you're not playing for 25 million dollar
purses unless the ratings support that
these people would understandably want a
profit whereas all that the Saudis
wanted was to launder their reputation
which if the deal goes through and you
have uh the head of the Saudi Investment
fund on the PGA tour board I would say
job well done you did it you've
laundered the reputation of a
reprehensible unconscionable uh regime
are you welcomed in Saudi Arabia
I don't plan on going to Ria at any time
okay but I'm just curious but look I I
think you know it's it this is not about
the Saudi people I I have no doubt
they're exactly like us they're you know
the vast majority of them want to have a
job uh want to have good health care
raise their kids put food on the table
and have a nice time in the evenings I'm
talking about the apocalyptic
apocalyptically radical uh uh leaders
and and in particular MBS who uh you
know his his human rights record is is
is not particularly good
play nice this week okay
I I hope we'll have a controversy-free
no no no no no no you want controversy
you you want that on the course you want
that right yeah of course on the course
of course but I wouldn't mind uh you
know some nice quiet evenings you know
where my phones
my wife would appreciate that maybe
maybe Mickelson just sneaks by one time
and uh stops by the set he's always
welcome on the set I'm sure he is all
our conflicts for all our conflicts I I
quite enjoy the man's golf
uh great to talk to you Brandel have fun
we'll be watching that's Randall
Chamblee Golf Channel lead analyst and
uh they'll be on coverage uh this entire
week on nearly 20 hours of weekend
coverage on NBC and of course Golf
Channel and the wrap-up shows uh they
have Championship coverage Thursday and
Friday from four to six Eastern